how's it going bros my name is hey
welcome back to Transylvania
hey little donkey holy [ __ ] huh
brah what I bet what's going on Oh James
yes it's me the pain are the pain taking
much I got raped in my body huh
bring dr. amis field bells around them
alright do you want me to kill you do
you want me to finish your pain ha ha ha
didn't work I was just kidding by the
way I would marry kill I love this dog
how look at that bone from that house
anyway welcome back to Transylvania
actually have fans from Transylvania I
thought I was kind of funny
apparently having vampires who watches
my videos I thought that was kind of
cool all right father
I'll help you nicely sorry but seriously
what does he be alright
I'll do I like it can I don't like these
creepy corridors it's gonna be more
laughs again now get them it's one of
those oh no I died
is it possible I thought I was why two
hits are you kidding me I will super get
what how is it possible
someone's that I had to make a pole in a
stake a stake in a pole no I didn't
confuse now wait there's our mission log
or something all I see is today's save
it hurt hurt hurt hurt I got them he's
gonna fall off the window now again oh
how is he still alive
ah okay we've been fools
hey fools you mean we don't keep much
longer the camp clean is a vampire ring
don't take my crucifix they're my
players will back away from it I am
wounded badly
perhaps I have half an hour you're dead
seriously no I can fall that far find
dr. Thomas field and bring him here and
I don't think I'll make it
probably now I'm sorry you can use the
main desert from where you came a
sanctuary the spawns of Hell do not
venture there
dr. average field Aunt Emily uncle grand
ring Gregor hiding in the East Wing you
must find a way to rescue them to the
hangar I best the pathway in the East
Wing with the green light to mark the
way all right
why the need to tell me sooner all right
give me your crucifix yeah
the power of say that I mean Jesus
comparison you like that
hey like oh you like that oh ye alright
bring it on demon I'm gonna say I'll
save here probably all right by the
power of this thing I will leave all
right vampire
I'm not afraid from you from like what
are you all right back up
yes yes oh no I didn't when I got that
out no let's try that again I didn't
worry I I could wire it all works in the
movies always they said it would back
off and don't on boy
apparently I'm not allowed shader
anymore I got got an evil message please
stop saying you don't understand I'm
sorry this when I don't hey Brian oh the
backstabbing son wow really
why would do you I don't even know why
I'm going here I just want more help I
guess it's okay I got this oh by the way
I check see recognize in the streets
today buy a bra not actually in the
street that was seen a star it was
really awesome
she brofist me okay I see where okay I
see you the power of Jesus
yes who's your [ __ ] now [ __ ] you like
that I should just stop doing that
all right let's try that I'm this
reminds I'm afraid of monsters no sudden
let's watch peopie die a million times
why not
why not alright let's not go I know
yes like that my god hurt her
higher East Wing I thought it gave me a
cure something I had a lot of help in
making us now hi sky this place how can
I die from one hit make no sense
oh god damn it now yet how do i dial the
[ __ ] time but na dun this is I'm
missing something here
like I in the last episode I didn't die
a lot of times I lied not a single time
actually and I have half health it's
impossible hmm something is fishy here
I don't trust this please maybe it's the
couch I just check some other [ __ ]
playback hey out for hellfish that's why
all I have for hell I thought it was my
something else
all right I am here to rescue the day I
need how fired at her her her her must
hurt my way over
it's a demon dog all I think doggie you
know speak Japanese
[ __ ] your dog a problem that's what you
get you freaking demon dog you know my
girlfriend's got a bigger stuff me Eli
was dogs all right
it was trying to scare me it's not my
fault all right
we have health packs here perfect
freakin be macaques no all right I don't
press these / - yes
give me all of your self acts let's save
it okay this looks very nice it's going
here
his path it's not green but whatever all
right hard up
hello anyone in here oh no it's this
graveyard outside of freaking haunted
castle that's like double girl Burke's
lebackes father a ville encyclopedia the
ghoul represent that more demonic aspect
of the spirit world and can spawn
anywhere within the castle town a ghoul
is similar to the vampire in that the
only animated dead people in human form
the ghoul however eats human flesh while
the vampire etics blood the kulak
Schneider buying well or intellect but
will back away from holy relic like a
crude this I had a crucifix it's awesome
ghouls come here girls
you're probably boys are right Wiggles
God got Dalek
Oh back up back up
yes back up oh no oh no no I was just
kidding haha alright I think that back
I'm nothing
I got that run well ours bummer
alright Jesus Christ they [ __ ] bug
lied to me
ah come on herb goat us everywhere
factors out got that was freaking cool
army hide in the toilet father David
encyclopedia of under the part five the
shadow vampire on Friday Ireland ancient
vampires the hollow and the weather
vallabha sorry I don't care I'm being
chased by [ __ ] backup Jesus Christ I
suck at this game fine at least I know
about the ghoul mm-hmm that helps that
helps a lot doesn't help at all
excu alright let's continue let's not go
there
he said green path green path have a
crucifix back up back up back up
there's no one here baby okay fine this
is place
that's what you get for killing me in
penumbra
freakin million times I thought it was
green horse path green this is not the
good battles why should I go I really
don uh I just want to find the record
line and kill them
blood everywhere
I mean period all right hey I have a gun
powder in bullets but I have not a
wooden stake yes
let's kill some mother effin my buyers I
need to learn the controls all right I
controls there we go the miles Alan oh
of course no it makes no sense in
Fincher I can't spin my wheels page up
all right let's try that all right all
right all right
all right Rasim page up yes here we go
open the door please take down I have
this you can chop Oh
we're gonna chop some back [ __ ]
average now chop ha ha shut up all right
chopping time chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop all right question is which
way green path East Wing oh it's here
all right cool perfect hello father
you still laughs you're still fighting
for your life I feel happy for you ha
job oh holy [ __ ] I didn't need to do
right nice I didn't mean to do it
I got banned right later ha I'm sorry No
nah it was an accident
I said you tell no one ah got that at
that battle Sami this is not good I
think I need to I'm sorry I have to go I
don't know how lonely record I hope a
record for a decent amount of time some
pipes are so long or some episodes are
sure it's just what I do anyway if you
enjoyed please subscribe to come abroad
today like a favorite and all that kind
of stuff leave a comment about
stuff I'll see you tomorrow
oh god way up and stop
started out all right that thing is gone
that [ __ ] oh no all up in it yours good
daddy buddy naked don't wanna make you
guys it's worse
hey tell everybody naked guys